mark is with us in Atlanta hey Mark how
are you I'm doing good how about you
better than I deserve what's up um the
other day after I got off work I was
talking to my daughter and she's looking
to get in the cheerleading she's in
seventh grade and she she has kind of a
smart mouth she probably gets it to me I
mean I'm not as mood seven but a smart
mouth and we were just trying to talk to
her about you know respect and adults
doing good in school and the
cheerleading thanks for by trying to get
her doing something that'll maybe one
day she could you know get a couple
scholarship off of their something and I
never said it out loud before but as I
was talking to her I realized that
between my wife and me where we won't be
able to pay for college and it's one of
them it's just it kind of hit me right
then and I've been listening to you for
about a year now and I talked my wife
here in there about you know what I hear
you know people with their debt-free
scrapes and stuff and it's we we seem to
I get on board with doing it together
you know trying to figure out how to pay
stuff off I've told her about this
snowball and all that and uh and then
something else will come up that we need
and it gets put on a credit card that's
just more debt just keeps getting that
either I just I don't know so what's
your household income ah forty forty
five thousand before taxes okay um well
it sounds like you got a wake-up call
like you're gonna have to get serious
about this stuff and you're going to
have to somehow get her on board to
where the two of you get serious about
this stuff
so that you can you know start living
some of your dreams because this kid
this kids heading headlong into a mess
as far as College goes if you don't turn
something around agreed agree and I
really don't I mean some people get
scholarships being cheerleaders but not
many I know is just and so the truth is
I don't want that to be your college
plan you know I'd rather you have a real
one
that has a cop role that that has a high
probability yeah I just kind of work I
got the story it woke you up but it
didn't wake your wife up is what you're
saying cuz she turned us ran something
else up on a credit card so you guys are
going to have to have a decision that
we're going to do some things
differently in order to get some things
we've never gotten before and I think
the two of you need to go through
Financial Peace University I think to
get you on the same page would you do
that if I gave it to you yes sir can you
get her to go your wife I probably if
you can't don't go okay because it's
going to cause problems in your marriage
because you're going to get matter and
matter and matter about the stupidity
with the money if you go to Financial
Peace University and if she's not on
your team it's going to drive a wedge
between you okay because I'm going to
teach you to be pissed off about being
broke okay and and if you do that and
then she goes and runs up a credit card
after you're in this class you're going
to go bonkers man I mean anything will
work so you got to get her to go okay
okay you got to talk her into it some
way or another if you can get her to one
or two classes I think she'll stay but
just getting her up off the couch and
going over to the class is the big deal
so hold on and I'll have Kelly pick up
we will send you a well we'll hook you
guys up and get you guys into Financial
Peace University so that you can do that
so people that go to Financial Peace
University a lot of them are rich and
they want to do better and they want to
be on the same page with their spouse
about money a lot of them are broke and
they're trying to not be broke anymore
but most people that go to Financial
Peace University are just like regular
people they're not really rich they're
not really poor
they're not about to file bankruptcy and
they're not you know it's not a crisis
and they're not worth 10 million dollars
most people that go are just regular
people and go I make too much money and
I'm not efficiently getting my goals hit
and I need to know more about insurance
and I need to know more about
investments and I need to be on the same
page with my spouse and I want to win
with money and that's who's going to
Financial Peace University these days
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]